Okay guys, in this problem, a dump truck has an upfront cost of $100,000 and an expected
salvage value of $15,000.
It is expected to last 7 years before the truck falls apart.
What is the closest to the assumed value of the truck at the end of its 5th year of service
based on the straight line method of depreciation?
So the first thing we are going to do here is go to our PDF reference manual and
keyword search for depreciation.
That will take us to page 38 or 37 of our reference manual and if you start on 37 you can
just scroll down to 38 and get the equation for the straight line method of depreciation
which is provided.
So it is going to be dj equals c minus s sub n over n where dj is going to be the depreciation
value in your j.
c is going to be our cost.
S sub n is our salvage value in your n.
And n equals the expected life of the asset.
So we can start just plugging into the equation and filling it out.
So dj is what we are solving for.
dj is going to be $100,000.
S sub n is going to be $15,000.
And n is the total lifespan of the truck.
So solving for this we get $12,142 which is really dj but I prefer to think of it in this
problem as the rate of depreciation per year.
So we can do one final step now to get our answer and find the value after 5 years of depreciation
of this asset.
So we have got our initial value of the truck and we are going to subtract from that
5 years of linear depreciation.
We can think of this to match our units up as 5 years times 12,142 so that the units cancel
and we are left with a dollar to dollar comparison.
At the end result here would be $39,290 which we can see is very close to our answer of C.
If the problem had wanted to try to ask the question in a slightly different way, they
could have asked what is the amount that the truck depreciated by at the end of its fifth
year of service, at which case we would just need to solve for one more basic step.
So we now know the depreciated value at the end of 5 years.
So we simply could have subtracted the original value of the truck or the depreciated value
of the truck from the original value of the truck and gotten the amount that the truck
depreciated by at the end of 5 years.
In this case the answer would have been about $60,000.